this is what I call facemask freak-outs
you know I've made it clear I can't
stand seeing people walking around
without a mask just listen to this
exchange it's great I mean it's just
this is what we're dealing with I work
for Costco and I'm asking this member to
put on a mask because that is our
company policy
so either wear the mask and I'm not
doing it I woke up in a free country
he's going to take the cart away I woke
up in a free country I don't have to
wear a mask people can't even
fundamentally figure out how our country
works on the simplest level freedom
doesn't mean you get to do whatever the
[ __ ] you want whenever you want home and
not go to the grocery store if he
doesn't write your mask
that's his freedom one man went totally
nuts outside a Publix grocery store in
Florida they're all worried about their
rights but you're right to stay healthy
and to stay safe is irrelevant nothing
this guy in Pennsylvania tried to enter
a Giant Eagle grocery store without a
mask
I read the doctor's note it said this
man is an [ __ ] and I don't care if he
gets sick get him out of my office and I
feel so bad for grocery store workers
you're trying to make a living you're
trying to deliver food now looking for
the goodwill of others now you need to
be a bouncer and grocery store worker I
have a medical condition that I'm not
allowed to wear a mask and I'm not
required by HIPAA rules regulations
should I just close that Jake can we
shuffle so what does that look like I
have private things I want to get the
Navy I don't want
I have private stuff that I don't want
you to see okay well you guys have a
lawsuit you're not embarrassed to sit
there and argue with a poor guy working
in a grocery store but you're
embarrassed to let him pick up your
tampons for you so they're literally
calling the police on me because I'm not
putting this mask on there's so much
research that says that we actually are
in danger of having this mask I'm
breathing my own co2 do you understand
that person she went on to call everyone
else in the store wearing masks sheep
look at all of these sheep that are here
all wearing this mask it's actually
dangerous for them and it's doing
nothing for them a ninety-nine percent
survival rate you're all wearing masks
like sheep like sheep seriously it's
ridiculous you guys share that this is
what we're dealing with in America this
cannot be the new normal by the way just
so you don't think I'm being an [ __ ]
there were over 17,000 new coronavirus
cases yesterday I mean come on what are
we doing somebody help us even
high-pitch eric wore a mask yesterday I
went to the AT&T store and I wore masks
these people not wearing do it do it